in the stability lecture is actually
different than what is written in the
schedule uh it is conventional
equilibrium under viable curvature
bounds
while the title originally was
sponkering quite his end whatever i said
earlier
so max please go ahead thanks buzz uh
so i apologize and um
and that was right the the title in the
schedule is more appropriate and that i
will spend more time talking about
poincare inequalities and convergence to
equilibrium
uh yeah so um
this is this is based on a joint worth
with uh
patrick cacho here and toulouse as well
as arnold
and roughly speaking the for those of
you who
are already familiar with this is uh the
goal was to
to go beyond the bacterium rich
criterion for convergence
to equilibrium and poincare inequalities
for diffusion processes
uh using uh an average notion of
curvature rather than point wise lower
bounds
so to to to to talk about the setting
uh it's really going to be about uh
long time behavior for the the following
stochastic process
so we we take a gradient descent
equation
and we we add a brownian noise to it
so here where uh we have some potential
v
we we seek to minimize it but we we
still have some some kind of noise
so this is uh this is a markov process
it has a nice explicit generator which
is the laplacian
distorted by a first order term that
takes the the gradient of the potential
so this is the the generator acting on
functions
and for for normalization procedures i
will assume
that v grows to infinity fast enough so
that the exponential of minus v
integrable and up to adding a constant
we assume that the
the total this total mass is one
and then uh it turns out that uh
there is a unique invariant probability
measure for this diffusion
which is the measure with density
exponential of minus v
and the the question we're looking to is
uh
how fast does the the the law of xt
converges
to this uh unique equilibrium measure
and uh there are numerous uh motivations
from this uh one is uh
about that this kind of equations arise
for several models of statistical
physics
for example some uh the the
particle system chef i spoke about in
his talk yesterday
can be written in this form
but uh it is also useful for a question
that arises for numerical simulations
say we want to uh simulate this
this uh this measure mu well one way to
simulate this
to design a markov process that has view
as an invariant measure
so this this is one possible markov
process that has written their measure
and so one way of simulating mu is to
simulate this dynamic and wait for a
long enough time so that we we are close
enough to the
invariant measure and of course
to to concretely to have theoretical
guarantees on the
on how efficient this kind of simulation
is we need to know how
fast how long it takes for this dynamic
to go to equilibrium
okay so so here a bit of uh
so once we we start thinking about how
fast we reconvert to equilibrium we
well we need to to to talk about
what notion we use to measure a rate of
convergence
and of course there are many ways of
measuring uh the rate of convergence
and one is is to look at what happens in
is to look at l2 convergence
so here if we look at the the generator
of this diffusion
this is a symmetric operator in the l2
space weighted by mu
and therefore a long time behavior of
the process
will be related to the spectrum of this
of the generator
so if we integrate by parts we can see
that
the integral of the operator l applied
to some test function f
multiplied by g is just the average of
gradient of f dot
product gradient of g so this here
includes the the symmetry of
of l and then it says that
um having a lower bound
on the positive eigenvalues of l is the
same
as looking at a poincare inequality
and controlling the variance of some
test function
by some constant times the l2 norm of
the gradient
and in which case the inverse of this
constant cp
is a lower bound on the positive
eigenvalues of minus l so why are we
looking at the variance and not the uh
the l2 norm of course it's because uh
if we apply this generator to constants
we get zero
so the the generator has a kernel it's
the set of constants
and we're looking at what happens
orthogonally to the set of constants
so functions with average zero and then
their their l to norm is the variance
okay so so uh it's the same thing as
looking at pounds on eigenvalues
is the same thing as looking for good
constants in these point
inequalities here and indeed we can show
that as soon as a quantity inequality
holds
if we start with some uh if we look at
the the density
of the of the law at time t with respect
to mu
then uh the l2 norm
of the of the density will decay
exponentially fast
and the rate of decay is controlled by
the partial constants
okay
here since the the topic of the
conference is concentration of measure i
guess i should talk a bit about the
the connection between these pancake
inequalities and concentration of
measure
and it turns out that these prank card
inequalities actually imply a
sub exponential concentration properties
if you look at any uh if you have a
poincare inequality
and then you look at uh deviation from
average for lipschitz test functions
they are they they decay exponentially
and uh we can control the decay rates by
the square root of the poincare
constants
uh so in here the the constants are
i don't think this is the version with
the sharp constants but uh
okay uh the the the sharp constant in
the
exponential decay property should be in
general is in general comparable to the
square root of the quantity constant
so uh in general the implication in only
one direction pointer inequality is
stronger than the sub-exponential
concentration
but the reverse is also true if we have
a if v is assumed to be complex
so this is a result emmanuel proved a
bit over 10 years ago
thank you yeah
sorry but i didn't hear you it could be
my problem but i could
for 15 seconds i could not hear your
voice maybe other people did you hear
your voice it was just my connection
okay since i have a heart attack i'm
saying this is just your connection
it's probably your connection yeah i i i
have a hard time hearing your boss too
so
is is there anyone else with uh who has
a hard time uh hearing me or
i can hear you very well okay and then
sorry boys uh
okay so another important property of
these poincare inequalities which kind
of govern
uh which are one of the motivation why
we're interested in is the the
tensorization property
if you look at an endfold product
measure
the sharp quantity constant is also the
quantity constant of the marginal
so so this sensorization property is at
the root of the fact that these uh
inequalities tend to behave quite well
in high dimension
okay so uh there are of course many
tools for proving pancake qualities i
would like to focus on one of them among
many
which is uh what is often called a
particular case of the bacterium btrm
but is actually a bit older
is that if we look at uh uniformly
convex potentials
so if the hessian of the potential v is
bounded from below time by
alpha times the identity with some
positive constant alpha
then we we can control the point array
constant by one over alpha
so of course the larger alpha has the
smaller the point array constant is and
the better the inequality becomes
so uh to my knowledge the the first time
this uh this result appeared uh
explicitly is in a work by brass convent
leave in the late 70s
but uh in our modern understanding of
this kind of inequalities is that
essentially this is a particular case of
the the modern generalization of a
result of volitionarovic
in the 50s and then there were later
works by backfield
and uh a later work by cafarelli we
proved this result using optimal
transport
so this is actually a sharp bone bound
in general
because it actually captures the the
best constant for the
for gaussian distribution if you look at
the standard gaussian distribution
so v is like one half of x squared up to
a constant
then the sharp constant there would be
one and indeed it turns out that the
constant one
is the sharp constant for the gaussian
distribution
so in general this is a this is a sharp
result
and uh also notice that the dimension
plays no role here
so it's uh it's completely dimension
free and this is crucial for many
applications
okay this result is actually um
the kind of the acclimation version of a
more general statement
that actually says that in the geometric
setting with
what matters is a is a lower bound on
the richie curvature of the manifold
and this is actually the constant
content of lichenervice's theorem
and which is why we we often talk about
these lower bounds on the hessian
as the curvature lower band by uh
because it really plays the same role as
the curvature in the geometric setting
okay so there are as i mentioned there
are many proofs of this
one way is via the the bachelor memory
gradient estimate
which states that if pt is the the semi
group
generated by by the
by the generator l so it's pt is
exponential of minus t l here
then uh the gradient of some pt
applied to some test function f is
exponentially decaying with a pre-factor
that's
pt applied to the norm of the gradient
or left so we have a sub-communication
relationship
between the semi-group and the norm of
the gradient
with a pre-factor that's exponentially
decaying
it's like exponential minus alpha t
where alpha is this lower bound on the
hessian
i will not prove this because i will
later give a sketch of a proof of a more
general statement
but given this uh this subcommunication
down
the proof of the the inequality is quite
is quite easy
so we can rewrite the variance of f
as the integral of the derivative of the
derivative of the l2 norm
along the flow generated by the semi
group
but a computation shows that
the derivative of the l2 norm along the
flow
is the l2 norm of the gradient so the
variance is really the integral of zero
to infinity
of the integral of
of the output norm of a gradient ptf
average from time going from zero to
infinity and then if we plug in this
this gradient bound
i forgot a factor two here
this is less than exponential of minus 2
alpha t times pt of grad s squared
but now if we average pt of grad f
against mu the the pt doesn't appear
anymore
because mu is in variance under the flow
so now we we can reintegrate the
exponential
and we get that the variance is bounded
by the l2 norm of the gradient
with a pre-factor one over alpha
and more generally if we want to prove a
point our inequality
it is enough to get a gradient an
exponentially decaying gradient bound
for uh lipschitz test functions and we
can afford for a prefactor actually
uh okay this is because of the the
spectral nature of the
the inequality the prefactor doesn't
really matter in the end
so max sorry to interrupt but uh it's
enough to show it just for one lectures
functions are
you're assuming like complexity okay
here i'm assuming uh
when lipschitz functions are nicely
dense or core
okay but you would just get a good
bound on the variance for one which
functions no
[Music]
so if um
sorry that's when lipschitz slipped um
you know if you if you if you um
okay what you're saying is uh it is
right that the variance bound is not
enough unless we assume convexity
yes you're entirely right uh and this is
my bad for recycling size for from half
a year ago
uh so so um but if you put
if it's normal it's fine yeah you're
right there's a
uh you you you need uh you need to take
into account elections
yeah because then if if you run the
spectral expansion you see that what
matters is really the the rate of decay
and not the prefactors
but this is assuming uh that lipschitz
functions are nicely dense
and of course it's not one lectures
function in sweatshirt functions
okay so another uh consequence of the
these gradient bounds is the convergence
to equilibrium and w1 distance
so what's the w1 distance uh if you look
at
two uh measures mu and u yeah
so this l1 vassar's time distance is the
supremum of the difference
of averages over all when lipschitz test
functions
and by by convex duality this is also
the
the minimization in an optimal transport
problem in that
if we look at all couplings of
mu and u so here by uh this is the
infimum over
all measures by on the product space
whose first marginal
is mu and second marginal is new and
then we minimize
the l1 distance over all possible
couplings
these two quantities coincide and they
they define a distance
on the space of probability measures
which meant rises a weak convergence
plus convergence of the first moment so
it's a nice distance
on the space of probability measures
and if we have a gradient bound then it
actually it also implies convergence to
equilibrium and vasterstein distance
because when electric speed functions
become more and more like just
so if we have this gradient bound and we
apply it to a one lapses function
we see that pt of f becomes exponential
of minus alpha t which is
at positive times t and then the vessel
stein distance between
the law at time t and the equilibrium
measure uh
we can write it as the supreme over
images of lipschitz functions by
the semi group pt and because because
they become more lip sheds
we get a an extra prefactor that's
exponential of minus alpha t
so this uh so this gradient this is not
in general equivalent to poincare
inequality itself this is just to say
that gradient bounds
imply convergence to equilibrium for two
different uh notions of metrics
and uh often this faster stain one
distance is a better metric
uh than l2 conversions for high
dimensional applications
mostly because for for kind of generic
data this prefactor here
scales like square root of the dimension
because this is like the size of the
typical distance between
two measures while uh the prefactor in
l2 convergence here
is typically exponential in the
dimension
okay so the motivation of what i would
like to talk about today is
about uh weakening the requirement of a
of a uniform
lower bound on on the hessian
and the starting point was a is a
general representation of the the
gradient of pt of f
so if now we we look at the hessian of v
at some point x
and we look at the lower bound on the
eigenvalues so i'm assuming that at a
point
x uh the hash of v is controlled
by alpha of x times the identity in the
sense of
symmetric matrices for some function
alpha
and what follows what what matters is
that alpha is bounded from below
but not necessarily by a positive
constant it can be any constants
we kind of need it to be bounded from
below to assume that everything is
nicely well posed
and then we can show that the norm
of the gradient of pt of f evaluated at
some point x
is bounded from above by the expectation
of the norm of gradient of f evaluated
at
some point at the the point x t
and this is the expectation for the
diffusion process started
at the point x if i forgot to specify
this
little x but with some extra
factor which is exponential of minus
uh the additive function of of alpha
along the trajectory up to time t
so in some sense uh we are looking at
how we accumulate curvature
along a trajectory and this is a
an extra exponential factor that bounce
the the range of pt of f
and of course if alpha is bounded from
below by some positive constants
we immediately uh recover this
now
so i i i don't actually know where this
inequality first appeared so uh
i i first learned it's in some work of
uh broad haberman and storm
who proved this inequality in a much
more broader setting of the so-called
rcd spaces so non-split metric measure
spaces that are
locally albertium but
it's it's it's been known for a while
and uh
this kind of uh formula actually goes
back to a
work of bismuth on malia calculus so i i
don't know where this
yeah could you comment on when is it
sharp
this is so interesting so we in in the
case uh
where alpha is is uh where uh alpha is
bounded from below by a
constant uh this is this actually uh
essentially sharp for the uh original
index process
uh actually no the l2 version of this is
sharp for the archdiocese i'm not sure
if the l1 version is sharp
uh no actually and there is one case
where it is sharp
but if it's not a constant that's
actually what i'm like if alpha
the non-constant case sharpness is not
and no one has ever looked at sharpness
i thought okay may i just comment
sorry just to finish answering galina's
question because there is one important
case
where the l1 version is known is a sharp
is that if you look at the manifold with
non-negative curvature
you have graph pt of f of x is less than
exponential of grad f of x t
norm of gravity and actually this is
sharp if and only if the manifold splits
off a line so you you kind of have an
encoding
of uh trigger grammar style splitting
theorems
by these kind of gradient bounds thanks
sorry boys you you had a question no i
just want to comment that there isn't
uh an identity which is not so far from
this inequality so you can express the
kind of ptf as some kind of
yeah this is the this is the dispute
formula in maria mariavan calculus
i guess that's where so
yeah so b smith has some work on exact
representations of gradients
and hashems of ptf and if you start
looking at this formula you can deduce
from them
this kind of bounce
uh so now i would like to give a sketch
of the proof
here not of the the general dismiss
formula but
just of these dance so what you can do
is that you you can couple two processes
with starting from different initial
conditions
but using the the same brownian motion
here so so this gives you two two
realizations of two stochastic processes
but there are a couple
and uh using the lower bound that's a
lower bound on the the gradients
by uh well the scalar product between
grad
gradient difference of gradients of v
and two points by uh
the the kind of the the curvature low
bound average on the curve going from
the two points
we can show that uh in a pointwise sense
this quantity is monotone
just from the coupling so you
differentiate this in time you you write
down the
ito's formula and you can get that this
is decay
this is this is decaying so in
particular it's bounded from above
by the initial condition which is just
the distance between your initial data
and now to go from this to the gradient
bound you can test out
the expectation of f of x t
with the sum which is function uh
divide by x minus y uh let y go to x
and then this this as soon as you assume
at least alpha is continuous
this you end up with alpha the
this quantity here
so you indeed end up with the additive
functional
of your curvature lower bound along the
flow
okay so now if we only consider when
lipschitz functions
uh the this here the the dependence on
the endpoint
we can simply bound it by one
so we can get that uh gradient of ptf of
x
is bounded from above by
uh the expectation starting from x
of the exponential of your additive
function of alpha
and so to to to prove either convergence
to equilibrium and w1 distance or some
kind of point
inequality uh what we aim
is to get a bound of the form um
uh the expectation starting from some
point x
of this additive functional we want we
aim to get some kind of exponentially
decaying
bound with possibly some prefactor the
prefectures don't really matter
but of course because of the the ergodic
theorem for markov process
we expect that uh the additive
functional along the flow
scales like t times the expectation at
equilibrium so what we expect kind of
expects
is that is that this should kind of
decay like exponential of minus t times
the
average of alpha and not a slower belt
at the first glance this is what you
might expect
yes and and and why would this uh
replacement of the lower bound by uh
by the average is interesting we have
two main
one is of course as you can guess is
that
if the curvature is negative in some
small region but
positive in most spaces we don't have a
uniform positive bound
but the average curvature should still
be nice
so we we and in these situations we
actually do expect
that exponential convergence equilibrium
to still occur
so so maybe average curvature would be a
good tool to kind of
quantify this the second motivation is
that even in the
the case where alpha is bounded from
below by a positive constant
uh we the backhammer ethereum is
actually uh
uh sharp in the sense that's uh sorry
rigid
in the sense that uh we have equality
here
if and only if we have equality here
pointwise
almost everywhere so the only
measure for which uh measures for which
uh the poincare constant is exactly
alpha minus one here
are measures for which in a point-wise
sense the smallest
uh eigenvalue of the hessian of e is
also alpha
and actually these measures are our
product measures
where one factor is gaussian so we kind
of have a splitting theorem in that
we have equality in the backlink theorem
if and only if
uh the measure splits off a gaussian
factor
uh so uh these are this is a particular
instance of
geometric terms that were proved by uh
chang and
a few years ago and so what happens is
that
um any positive variable curve
but virtually variable curvature bound
should lead to a strict improvement of
the bachelorette
bound in that any case
where we have this bound by some some
positive constants but where the uh
this function alpha of x is not constant
the point a constant should be strictly
better than the one predicted by the
constant curvature case
and a a a result in this direction was
already obtained by
in 2011 where we showed that we can
replace the
pointwise lower bound on the curvature
by the heart by a harmonic mean
so the one over the average of one over
alpha
as soon as alpha strictly positive
everywhere
so what i will i will talk about there
interface as a result but that is
not directly comparable
okay so that's the nice picture but uh
at this the picture i just described
cannot work
we actually cannot expect this
exponential decay to hold with the
prefactor just
the average of the curvature and it
already should break down in dimension
one
and why is that is that well what's the
the best possible lower bound on the
eigenvalues of the hessian of v in
dimension one
that's just the second derivative of e
so the average
curvature is going to be the average of
the second derivative of v
with respect to exponential minus v but
we can integrate by parts
and this is the average of v prime
squared so it's always
strictly positive
so we always have strictly positive
average curvature in dimension one
but uh we don't always have exponential
convergence to equilibrium
it is not too difficult to uh produce
examples of
these that do not grow to infinity fast
enough for such
exponential decay to occur for example
uh
if you take v of x as some kind of
constant times log
we get uh we get some kind of uh
polynomial decays to equilibrium but we
don't get exponential decays to
equilibrium
so uh the the picture that well maybe we
can just replace
uniform lower bounds by average of
curvature is is
too optimistic it's not going to work
and what is the gap uh the gap is that
the ergodic theorem is qualitative this
is the limit
but what we would need here is to do
some kind of quantitative
ergodic theorem to get such a such a
bound at a fixed time t
and it is in the this uh so what we need
is a
rate of convergence not maybe not for
everything but at least for the
observable alpha
so we and the principle here is that if
we have some
uh quantitative ergodic theorem for a
single observable
then we can deduce uh rates of
convergence to equilibrium
for uh in l2 for for faster stein
distances and
for other norms too
okay so how do we get uh bounce on
the rate of convergence in the ergodic
theorem
when answer was given by a theorem of
guillain
leonard about 10 years ago
which is the following it shows that an
equivalence
between um
uh bounds on probabilities of seeing a
significant deviation
in the ergodic theorem and a certain
type of
types of functional inequalities which
are known as a transport and formation
inequalities
so the statement is that uh for
any one lipschitz function
with respect to some distance d which is
not necessarily the eclidium distance
having some kind of exponential upper
bounds on probability of deviation
starting from some initial data that has
a density with respect to mu
and with a then with a prefactor that's
like the l2 norm of of the density
is the same as being able to bound the
the vesterstein one distance but with
respect to this particular distance
squared by the the fischer information
so the l2 norm of the grange of the log
of the density
so we have to we have a reference
reference node remu
we look at some other measure with the
density rho
and always being able to bound faster
steinwis vasserstein went distance
by the fischer information is equivalent
to having
exponential bounds on the probability of
observing significant deviations
and and the the the insight behind this
theorem is that uh
the fischer information is actually the
the large deviation rate function
for large deviation principles for
additive functions
okay so this uh this theorem gives a
kind of a functional
tool for for uh for controlling
errors in the ergodic theorem at least
four
observables that are that satisfy a
regularity
estimate and then by markov's inequality
uh from this we can really get actual
rates of convergence in the ergodic
theorem
and there are two subcases of interest
here one is the case where the
g is the eclidean distance so now we we
get
the standard vessel steinway distance
and the dysfunctional inequality is uh
is something that is known
uh it kind of has a place in the
hierarchy
of functional inequalities for those of
you who know it
it's weaker than the logarithmic sub f
inequality
but it's stronger than the gaussian
concentration
so for it to be true we at least need v
to grow quadratically at infinity
but there is another interesting case
which is when d is just a discrete
distance so
indicator of two points are differing
and then the admissible test functions
are just
downloaded functions so lipschitz
functions for the trivial distance
are just the bounded functions and uh
the functional inequality this transport
information inequality
is something that is actually strictly
weaker than the pointer inequality
itself
and indeed we can show that uh if a
point have inequality holds
then this inequality also would be the
discrete distance and the constant here
that is four times the point
constant
so these are two examples that come but
of course
in principle we could work with
different distances too
so uh one application now of this this
kind of
combining these these rates of
convergence in the ergodic theorem and
the variable uh bound on on
the variable gradient bound is a kind of
a self-improvement in the battery m
rebound
so say uh the hessian is bounded from
below by some function of alpha
which is itself bounded from below by
some positive constant
then we can bounce the poincare constant
from above not by one over alpha zero
but something strictly smaller with a
gain t
that looks at the the difference
between the average of the curvature
and the curvature lower bound and adds
in
some something extra that depends on the
the oscillations
of alpha so so you can think of this as
being the the super alpha minus the
n f of alpha and some extra
some extra factor here that also depends
on how
how far the average of the curvature and
the uniform lower bound r
and this uh this is always a strict
improvement
for measures that have full support and
for which the
average curvature is strictly better
than the
the uniform lower bound so it's a strict
improvement for any measure
that has full support and does not have
a gaussian factor
so that is not a product measure with
one factor being purely darshan
so okay so so this kind of quantifies
the idea that uh
gaussians are or the only cases in which
the backhand rebound is sharp
so maybe to give you a brief sketch of
the proof
so a priori we know that uh
the poincare constant is bounded from
above by one over alpha zero
and we know that this implies this
transport information inequality
with a constant s4 over alpha zero so we
have
a a rate in the ergodic theorem
and we plug it in here so we take our
curvature functions we
we use we reduce the bound
on this quantity from the priori bound
on the point at a constant
okay so first in in the probabilities of
deviation and then on the expectation
and the expect and expectation starting
from a point
and from this we we deduce
we take the gradient estimates and
we deduce an upper stereo rebound on the
poi k
constant from from this kind of argument
from the
from this gradient bound that is a
posteriori strictly better than the one
we started with
so we we kind of have an automatic
self-improvement of the the back family
theorem
as soon as the average curvature beats
the lower bound
so okay so that's just one example of
implementation of this strategy
uh i will not discuss other ones because
it
quickly becomes very logical
we we have other ways of implementing
this we can use log sub of inequalities
we can replace the average of the
curvature bound by some kind of median
we can use other kind of concentration
inequalities
and this is kind of like okay kind of a
whatever work strategy what matters is
that you you have plenty of ways
of getting rates of convergence in the
ergodic theorem
and what matters here is that actually
we
we only care about a single observable
so you can also try to get
an estimate on this hands-on on one
particular example
using say couplings or gear
sentence-type estimates or
a lot of a lot of tools are available we
have
a functional approach and then deduce
some kind of rate of convergence in the
ergodic theorem
and then boost and then plug this into
the strategy i just described
to then deduce rates of convergence to
equilibrium
uh just a few other notes this can also
be used to get convergence to
equilibrium in vesterstein
distance of order p
so by which i mean uh you take this
definition but you add in a power p here
in the
female overall couplings so these become
stronger
distances on the space of probability
measures
and because what's really at the core of
the argument is a kind of a coupling
argument
you can also get uh bounds on the va on
rates of convergence investors time p
distance
the rates become worse as big or large
and we also need an extra technical
requirement
in that we need to stretch and to
strengthen the hessian lower bound
into some kind of uh point-wise lower
bound
that only depends on the endpoints so
the scalar product between grad v of x
and gravity of y
product f plus minus y should be bounded
from bellow by
x minus y square times the prefactor
that only depends on the endpoint
so it's kind of kind of stronger than
the
requirement here that we had used in
some kind of interpolated way the point
here is that
we kind of need to make it depend on the
to get vessels time distance estimates
we can only care about the end points
and not about what happens on the path
to interpolate between between the two
points
okay uh so for example this can be used
to get a wp rates would be strictly
larger than two
if a log sub of inequality holds that's
for one example of my menu that you can
get out of this
uh okay so that's about all i wanted to
discuss today thank you very much for
your attention you max for this
very interesting talk um are there any
questions
too much
so so let me ask a question it could be
that you already answered during these
15 seconds that they could not hear you
um so what's the um
you just mentioned passing this result
by the vassar
sir can you
elaborate so what you can show is what
he showed is that you can bound the
point
a constant by uh the harmonic mean of
this function alpha of x
so assuming it is strictly positive you
average one over alpha
then you take the inverse of this so
this is strictly uh
better than the lower bound and but
worse than the average of alpha
and from this you can get uh also get a
bound on the
point a constant so the two results are
the this result is not comparable with
what i described in general
because uh in the implementation of this
strategy
we never get as a rate the true average
but we also get some always get some
extra terms that depend on the the rate
of conversions in the ergodic cure so we
never get the true
average but always something a bit worse
you see and is there any hope for a
matrix version of alpha or this is
beyond any
okay this is uh yeah so
some natural question is to try to get
some kind of a
complete version of this
good question
it's a bit harder to to get kind of
hands-on controls on the
matrix version by this kind of coupling
arguments so first thing you one would
have to do with some kind of
this bit formula with matrix weights
oh okay okay so did this actually exist
already
i don't know i think um
box can i ask a question yeah
max can i ask a question yes uh i i must
be missing some technical point in your
proof but
it looks to me that you need to control
the a
lower deviation large deviation for the
integral of alpha x s being small
so you really need to worry about are
being negative
uh and in that case i don't see how why
the
the kind of gaussian bounds you get from
the
from the information uh transpose so
here
the the the version i kind of described
where everything works nicely is uh
we also we have a uniform positive bound
and then we bootstrap something stronger
if if alpha is allowed to be negative
well you kind of have an optimization
problem that that comes out of it
in that you have some loss from the
negative parts
you have some gain from the parts where
alpha is positive you have some loss
from the rate of convergence
to the ergodic average and you have to
figure out if everything balances well
to get an estimate
but what really matters but what i'm
missing is this if ci
would have been extremely large then i
think you will you will lose
if if ci is extremely large
and uh yeah it is possible in in some
regime where the fluctuations of alpha
are large
and ci is really large that we in the
optimization we just don't get anything
okay this is possible so it's important
here that ci is related to cp
that's crucial to to being always
successful so
the the fact that it's always successful
in the back application to the
self-improvement in the background
ethereum
is indeed because ci and cpr are already
related
okay we we if we have a
kind of no connect so maybe to give you
an example where everything is going to
break down
um no okay no sorry
the example i was thinking of is not
going to work but yeah
okay yeah one example where everything
is going to break down imagine a
situation
where alpha is positive on a very large
region
but negative at infinity
uh then okay uh
this is not gonna work really uh
well if you try to work with this ci
it's not gonna work because ci is going
to be infinity
but um
yeah you you okay you can build by hand
examples where
you have some ci that's terrible uh the
oscillations of
of alpha are large enough that uh ci is
not good enough to compensate and
you try to optimize and you get
something that's never good
thank you question max
i'm sure you thought of it so in this uh
is there a version of this theorem where
you replace
the usual washer style and by
[Music]
mass yanmas or urban mass curvature
so one thing that's going to be
um so we okay so we we haven't tried to
uh
implement this because uh what's the the
the the the really annoying thing in the
error mass setting is that
uh to define the curvature we need to
lift everything
to this place of probability measures
so the analog of some variable curvature
bound
is not going to be something that's
going to to live
on on the face on the the physical space
it has to be a function of probability
measures
and now we we we get up at some
non-trivial ways
oh maybe there is a way of connecting
everything
but it's not going to be as nice as this
because we are really
to define the variable curvature we
really have to lift everything
so what's the the the natural way of
lifting
the ergodic trm
to connect things and then the the other
thing that's not so nice
is the fact that in the discrete setting
the
the fischer information used for the
transport information inequalities
and the natural fissure information and
the gradient flow structure so the
entropy productions are not the same
anymore right
so that these are kind of the two
sources of
of why white would certainly be a
non-trivial endeavor
yeah thank you
any further questions deluxe
yeah i can ask a question sure
hi max thanks for the talk is that is
there anything interesting to say about
cases of
negative curvature so uh
so as i said it's like you you can show
examples where uh
uh you have negative curvature in some
region positive and
yeah but positive at infinity and show
by hand that you can get estimates out
of this
i didn't show any example because it's
all we did is extremely zoological
really it's like
give me an example we try to do things
and uh if if things are not too bad we
can do it
but it's like we we
do we don't have a mat a nice matte
matter cram in the same way as this
it really is here's an example here's
how to to try to tackle it and maybe it
works maybe it doesn't
so yes and no i guess we'll see
thanks
maybe just to continue on on don
mcgreen's question um
i think supposed to consider the other
extremes that you have say
uh a surface of genus two with
hyperbolic metal constant curvature
minus one
is there anything
well maybe it's uh no i i i i think if
you do this
we do have a we do have expansion of
distances along the uh
yeah i mean
[Music]
okay any further questions
um so let's thank max again and
we meet again at 11 30 pacific time for
garina's talk
bye bye